Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: So,
so far here is what we have
done.
We've been studying the whole
time this analogue of Newton's
law: τ = Iα.
So, after teaching you what
τ is and what I
is and what α is,
in the early days I
concentrated on problems where
τ is not zero.
There is some object on which
some torques are acting and in
responds to the torques--in
response to the torques,
the body will accelerate.
Then, we went to another class
of problems where there were no
external torques,
there are only torques from
inside.
Excuse me, will you people who
come late use the other door?
Yeah, you're blocking actually
the taping right now.
Yes.
All right.
So, today, I'm going to
consider an extreme case where
there is no torque at all.
If there's no torque,
we know α is zero and
the angular velocity is
constant.
But I'm going to take a case
where even angular velocity is
zero.
There is no motion;
there is no torque.
So you can say,
"You know, what's there to
study?"
Well, sometimes it's of great
interest to us that the object
has no angular velocity.
A common example is,
you are trying to do something
in your house,
you get up on a ladder,
that's somewhere there.
This ladder should have no
angular velocity.
Right?
That's not a trivial statement
to a person who is going up
there.
So you want to ask,
"What does it take to keep the
ladder from falling over?"
Okay, that's what we're going
to discuss.
All right.
So, let me start with a simple
problem and take some horizontal
rod like this.
And I say, "What does it take
to keep the rod from moving
around?"
And the first thing,
you know, is the forces on it
should add up to zero because
otherwise F = ma tells
you this rod's going to be
flying off somewhere.
So, I've taken a body,
a rod of length L,
and I don't want it to move at
all.
So, total forces adding up to
zero we know is not good enough
because here is the problem
where I apply two forces equal
and opposite,
add up to zero,
but that doesn't do it.
This rod will still rotate.
It is still true that when the
total forces add up to zero,
the center of mass will not
accelerate.
But that doesn't mean the body
will not move because keeping
the center of mass fixed,
the body can rotate.
All right.
So, you have to ask yourself,
"What does it take to keep it
from rotating?"
Then we know that the cause of
rotation is the torque.
So, I'm going to write down now
the conditions for a body,
a planar body lying in the
plane of the blackboard,
to stay still and not move.
They are that all the forces in
the x direction.
i is some label,
force number 1,
force number 2.
That should add up to zero.
All the forces in the y
direction;
that should add up to zero.
This will make sure the center
of mass as a whole is not going
anywhere.
And finally,
to keep the body from moving or
spinning, all the torques should
add up to zero.
So, bulk of the lecture today
will just be dealing with this
condition.
So, what we're going to study
today is a collection of objects
that are somehow subject to a
variety of forces but still in
equilibrium,
in static equilibrium.
That means they are not moving.
So, simplest problem from the
family is a seesaw.
Let's say that's a point where
the seesaw is supported and
let's say we put one kid here
applying some force
F_1.
So F_1 is the
mg for the kid.
And let's say this end is a
distance x_1
from the support.
The question is,
"How much of a kid should I put
here to keep this in balance?"
It should not move under the
combined weight of these two
kids.
So, I take the body and I write
down all the forces on it.
So, I have F_1
coming down here.
I have F_2
there.
Then there is--Of course,
that cannot be the whole story
because the seesaw is not going
into the ground.
That is the support and the
normal force from the support.
And these three forces together
should conspire to keep the body
in equilibrium.
So let's see.
So, here is what I want you to
understand.
F_1 is known.
Let's give it some name,
100 Newtons.
This distance
x_1 is also
known.
That distance
x_2 is also
known.
I'm trying to find out what
force F_2 is
needed.
So, F_2 is
what I'm trying to solve for.
So, I write all the equations I
know.
So, horizontally,
there's nothing going on.
So, it's zero equals zero.
In the vertical direction,
I have F_1
pushing down,
F_2 pushing
down equals N.
And that's not going to be
enough to solve this problem
because I have two unknowns.
I don't know N and I
don't know F_2.
I just know this guy.
So, that's where the torque
equation's going to come in.
Now, here is the subtlety when
you do the torque in this
problem.
So, how do you find the torque
due to any force?
Can you tell me what you're
supposed to do?
Yeah?
Yes, you, yes.
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Right.
What r should I use for
this force?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Pardon me?
x_1?
Okay, why did you choose that?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Okay.
Her answer was,
"That's the pivot so I chose
that distance."
The point is,
when we say the body has no net
torque, which means it's not
rotating around some axis.
If there is an axis around
which a body is rotating,
then we know how to take the
torques through that axis.
When a body is not rotating,
it's not rotating around any
axis whatsoever.
So, you can say it's not
rotating through an axis I draw
through here.
So, I will take all the torque
with respect to that point.
Someone else can say,
"No, it's not rotating through
that either.
I will take all torques from
that point."
If you change your mind on
where you're taking the torque,
then the torques are all
changing because in the force
times distance the distances are
going to change.
So, now we have a predicament
where for every possible point
around which I compute a torque,
I will get a condition
involving the different forces
and the distances from that
point.
So, I can write down an
infinite number of equations for
each different choice of pivot
point.
But I only have two unknowns,
F_2 and
N.
Two unknowns can only satisfy
two equations,
not 2,000 equations.
So, we've got to hope that the
extra equations I get by varying
the pivot point all say the same
thing.
And that's what I will show you.
I will show you,
first, that if you have a bunch
of forces that add up to zero,
then it doesn't matter around
which point you compute the
torque.
If it was zero around one
point, then it will be zero
around any other point.
Suppose I pick some point here
and I take each force,
multiply the distance of that
force from that pivot point and
they added up to zero.
Now you come along and say,
"No, I want to take the torque
around that point."
What you will be computing will
be the same force,
but to every
x_i you will
add a distance a where
a is the distance by
which you moved your axis.
Now, let's open this out.
You'll find it is
F_ix_i +
a times sum of all the
F_is.
This is zero because for me the
torque around that point
vanished and this is zero
because all the forces add up to
zero.
In other words,
if you find any one point and
make sure the torques around
that point don't cause--that
they all add up to zero,
then the torque around any
other point will also add up to
zero, provided the sum of the
forces adds up to zero.
And of course,
that's the problem we're
looking at.
So, you've got to realize that
when you take the torque,
you may pick any point you
like.
Now, that's where a strategic
issue comes up.
If you were asked simply to
find what F_2
is, not to completely solve the
problem,
which would be also finding
what the normal force is--if
someone said,
"Just find
F_2,"
I don't care what N is"
then, there's a particular
choice of pivot point that is
optimal.
That choice is the one in which
this normal force doesn't get to
enter the torque equation and I
think you all know what I mean.
Pick that point as the point
around which you take the
torques;
then N drops out.
So, this is the usual model
when you take torques.
Always take the torque through
a point where an unknown force
is acting because the unknown
force doesn't contribute to the
torque equation.
So in principle,
you can take the torque around
any point and you can satisfy
yourself in your spare time;
it doesn't matter which point
you take.
It will be the more complicated
way to solve the problem because
N will come into the
picture and no one asked you
what N is.
So, we take the point of
support and then,
of course here is the point of
support,
and what did I have,
F_1 here a
distance x_1,
I had F_2 at a
distance x_2.
This is the point around which
I'm doing the torque,
so N doesn't count.
Then, you get a condition
F_1x_1 =
F_2x_2.
From that you can solve for
F_2.
For example,
if this was one meter and this
was six meters,
and this was say 10 Newtons
here,
then 10 times one has to be six
times F_2.
So, 10 = 6F_2
and F_2 will be
10/6 Newtons.
I don't want to use N
because N is also
standing for the force here.
That's how we find
F_2.
Once you've found
F_2,
in case you want to know what
is the support going through and
how much load is it carrying,
you can come back now and add
F_1,
which was given to you,
and the F_2
you just solved for.
Then if you want to,
you can find N.
Even if you were asked to find
N, it's best to first
take torque around a point
N so N doesn't
enter,
find F_2,
then it's very trivial to add
F_1 and
F_2 to get
N.
This is the easiest prototype.
So, you guys have to know how
this is done.
Everything I do will be more
and more bells and whistles on
the simple notion of how to take
the torque.
All right.
So now, I'm going to take a
slightly more complicated
problem.
So, here is a wall and there is
a rod here of length L
and mass M.
And it's supported by some kind
of pivot on the wall.
And I want to hold it up by
supporting it here with a force
F.
And the question is,
"What force should I apply?"
Okay.
So, we know that if I draw the
free body diagram of the rod,
I have my force F;
I have gravity acting down
everywhere on the rod,
then the pivot,
namely the wall,
it can exert a certain vertical
force.
It can also exert a horizontal
No one tells you the wall is
frictionless or anything or the
pivot is frictionless.
So, the wall is exerting in
general a force,
which is at some oblique angle,
which I've broken up
conveniently into horizontal and
vertical parts.
What about gravity?
And torque due to gravity is
what I want to discuss now.
First of all,
I am only asking you to find
the force I have to apply to
support the rod.
So, just like the other
problem, I'm not asking you to
find v and h.
So the trick,
once more, is to jump straight
to the torque equation.
Forget about the force equation.
Go to the torque equation and
take the torque around this
point, then this guy is out.
No matter what's going on --
doesn't matter -- the torque due
to the pivot is out.
So, we have to equate the
torque due to the force I apply
to the torque due to gravity
pulling the rod down.
Torque due to force I apply;
that torque,
is equal to F times the
length of the rod because
there's F times r times
the sine of the angle between
them,
and the sine of the angle is 9,
the sine of 90,
which is one.
How about the torque due to the
pull of gravity?
Anybody know what we're
supposed to do here?
Yeah?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Okay.
Now, why is that?
Why is it okay to replace the
torque by the center of mass?
Yeah?
Either of you can answer, yes.
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Right.
But why am I allowed to pretend?
See, we can pretend a lot but
it occasionally has to
correspond to reality so that it
works.
So, why is it okay to pretend?
That's a correct answer.
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Right.
But if I really wanted to prove
it, somebody has a way to really
nail it down and show that it's
okay?
Yes?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Thank you.
Yes.
Your answer is right.
I know where you're going.
That's the right answer.
Look, what you want to do is
you always have to go back to
first principles.
You cannot take anything on
faith because you picked it up
on the street or someone
whispered this to you.
That's not good enough.
One lesson I want to show you
throughout the lectures is,
I cannot invoke new laws or new
principles.
The only principle we know is
F = ma.
You've got to go back to that
all the time.
Of course, there is the other
principle that gravity is an
extra force on the body.
But this is an external--This
is an extended object.
It's got a center of mass but
gravity is not necessarily
acting there.
It's pulling each part of it
down.
So, I want to show you that in
the end of course the answer is
as if all the mass were
concentrated here for the
purposes of torques but I want
to show you why.
So, the trick proposed by this
gentleman here--Imagine dividing
the rod into tiny pieces,
each of which is small enough
to say it has a definite
location x_i.
The torque, due to gravity
acting on that little
fellow--It's the mass of that
little guy times
x_i times
g.
If mg is the force,
then mg times
x_i is the
torque.
You want to sum it over all the
little pieces.
Sum over i is summing
over all the little pieces.
So, let me make my life easy by
dividing by the total mass and
multiplying by the total mass.
If I started this combination
m_ix
_i summed over
I divided by M,
that is the center of mass.
So, it does look like
Mgx, where x is
the center of mass of the rod.
Now, the rod really doesn't
have to be uniform for me to say
this.
It doesn't have to be a uniform
rod.
The mass can be distributed any
way it likes.
Each m_i need
not be the same.
But it's very important that
gravity be constant.
We demand that the force of
gravity have a constant value
over the length of the rod.
And it's not obvious that's
always true.
I mean, if I took a tiny rod,
force of gravity is
constant--took a very big rod,
comparable to the size of the
Earth, of course the pull of
gravity is varying on the length
of the rod.
But for all rods on the
laboratory scale,
that's not an issue.
And that's where this result
comes from.
Okay.
So, now that we know where the
result comes from,
we will now apply it in the
torque equation.
This is the torque due to the
force I apply Fx.
That's equal to Mg times
x, where x is the
location of the center of mass.
That is going to be half the
length of the rod.
I'm sorry-- this Fx is
FL.
We cancel the L,
then you find the force
I apply is Mg
divided by two.
Yeah?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: If the pivot is
exerting what force?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Yeah.
But it won't cause a torque.
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: I am finding--no.
Here, what I'm calculating is
not the net force.
I'm finding the torque around
this point due to the pull of
gravity on the different
segments that make up the rod.
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Oh.
But the pull of gravity is
straight down and the separation
is horizontal.
Is that the question now?
Student:
I want to know about the force
you're applying,
not the gravity.
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Well,
I'm--oh, the force I am
applying.
Oh, I am applying the force
here, straight up.
Oh, you want to know--
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Ah.
Well, you're quite right.
You're saying we don't know
a priori whether the
force I'm applying is vertical
or horizontal.
Correct?
Maybe that's your question.
That's actually a valid
question.
It's clear that I have to apply
vertical force and possibly
horizontal force to compensate.
This one, if there is a
horizontal force in the wall.
You're quite right.
Absolutely correct.
So, this F--I should
also divide the force that I
apply into a vertical part I
call F and a horizontal
part that I call H prime.
Then, it'll turn that in this
problem an H prime is not
needed.
You can sort of tell
intuitively if you're holding up
a plank, you know.
One end is anchored and you're
trying to support it;
it's enough to apply a vertical
force.
But I don't have to presume
that.
So, if you want,
you can think of applying
horizontal force.
But it's not necessary to hold
this in equilibrium.
Maybe the main point is,
a purely vertical force will
suffice to keep this in
equilibrium, is the point that
I'm making.
In fact, if that force is equal
to Mg/2,
it won't rotate.
Now, we can go back--now that I
find the force I have to apply
in this direction,
what force is at the pivot?
Well, the vertical force on the
pivot is pointing up.
My force that I calculated is
pointing up.
And together they should add up
to Mg.
Now, F = Mg/2 so the
vertical force will be
Mg/2.
Now, horizontal force--In this
problem, there is no need for
you to apply the horizontal
force and there's no need for
the pivot to fight you back with
the horizontal force.
It's not needed for
equilibrium, but supposed you
insisted.
Not only are we lifting it but
we are leaning into the rod.
Yes, then, you will apply
horizontal force.
It's not going to contribute to
the torque equation,
but if you push it in,
wall's got to push you out,
and H prime will be
equal to H.
In fact, let's turn to a
problem where the support,
in fact, exerts a horizontal
and vertical force.
So, that's the next level of
difficulty.
This is one of the standard
problems in the section and it
goes like this.
Here is a rod and it's
supported by a wire.
And the wire has a certain
tension T.
It is anchored to the wall;
the length of the rod is
L, the mass of the rod is
M.
And at the--This end is some
pivot, which is exerting some
unknown force,
which can have a horizontal and
vertical part.
We'll have a horizontal part
H and a vertical part
V.
Now, I know for sure there's a
horizontal part.
I think you can tell--can you
guys tell in your mind where
there's a horizontal part?
This force that's supporting it
is pushing the rod into the wall
and also pulling it up.
The part that's pushing it to
the left has to be compensated
by H.
But suppose the question they
ask you is, "What is the tension
on that rope?"
And suppose that's the crucial
issue because if the tension is
too much the rope is going to
break.
If you want only the tension,
once again the trick is,
forget the force equation and
go to the torque equation
because,
if you go to the torque
equation, you banish both
V and H.
I hope that's clear to all of
you.
A force going through the pivot
point in any direction is
incapable of producing any
torque.
That's so intuitively clear,
we need not belabor that.
If you want the formula in
F times r times
sin θ,
r is zero.
So, we don't care what the
angle is.
So, once again,
we'll take torques around this
point and see what it will tell
us.
So, the torque due to gravity,
we all agreed,
we can now replace by
MgL/2,
turning it this way.
So, this force exerts a torque
which is equal to the value of
the tension, the length of the
rod and the sine of the angle
between the two,
which is this angle here.
So, the nice thing is,
you can solve for the tension
directly in one shot,
which is just Mg/2
sin θ.
That's why θ cannot be
too small.
If θ is too small,
at some point T will
become so large that the string
will break.
So, if you want to anchor a
sign, you've got to try to take
a big angle like that so that
sin θ is not too small.
So, one of the problems you
could be asked is,
"What's the minimum
angle so that the rope doesn't
break,
given that it can support a
maximum tension of 1,000
Newtons?
Well, then you put a 1,000
Newtons here,
you know the M and the
g, you solve for the
θ at which it crosses a
thousand Newtons.
And your θ should be
bigger than that.
Yeah?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: That was a
definition of the torque.
If you go back,
then you've got to go back to
what we did earlier and you'll
find I deduced the other day--I
said--Maybe I'll remind you how
that happened.
I'm trying to the find the
analogue of F = ma.
Analogue of ma is
Iα.
And I said, "Who is the guy who
can play the role on the
left-hand side?"
And I found the quantity that
plays the role of Iα;
that's equal to Iα -- is the
force times distance times
sin θ.
Okay?
So, that's-- you-- look,
you've got to understand why
torque has a sin θ in
it.
If you want to rotate a body --
take any body that you want to
rotate -- you know,
here is a rod and you want to
rotate it, you pick a point,
you want to apply a force.
We know intuitively that any
force applied along this
direction is no use,
in terms of rotating it.
The best way to apply a force
of a given magnitude is to be
perpendicular to it.
But if, for some reason,
you can only apply it at some
angle, then this part of the
force is good for rotation and
that part of the force is not
good for rotation.
And the sin θ projects
out this part.
If that angle is θ,
then F sin θ is really
the perpendicular part of
F.
So, that's how the torque is
defined.
Okay.
So, we found the tension here.
If that's all you want to know,
that's the end of the problem.
You're got the tension.
But you may be asked to do more.
You could be asked to now find
what's happening at the pivot.
Then, you've got to go back to
the forces.
So, in the horizontal
direction, in the x
direction, the total forces have
to add to zero.
So, H should be equal to
F, which should be equal
to tension times cos θ
because this T has a T
sin θ that way and T cos
θ that way.
And this is T cos θ.
So, T cos θ is pushing
in, the wall should push out.
And now I know the value of
T.
I put that in.
Mg/2 cos θ
because that's cosine over sine.
All right.
So, that's the horizontal part.
How about the vertical part?
In the vertical direction,
upward vertical force plus T
sin θ has to be the
downward force,
which is Mg.
Well, we know what T sin
θ is.
We just did that.
T sin θ,
if you look up here,
T sin θ is Mg/2
= Mg.
That means V = Mg/2.
That means, the pivot provides
half the support,
half the mass.
And the tension's vertical part
provides the other part.
So, I will give you a couple of
seconds to think about this.
This is the kind of problem you
guys should be easily able to
do.
You isolate the rod,
you write all the forces on it.
If you want,
maybe this--If this picture is
not clear to you,
what I have in mind is,
I pull out the rod and say,
"Why is this rod not turning
and moving under all the forces
acting on it?"
Then I write the forces on it.
The tension is acting in that
direction;
the pivot has a vertical force,
the pivot has a horizontal
force, and gravity for this
purpose I'll replace as acting
there.
Under the action of all these
forces, the rod is neither
translating nor rotating.
That means the x
component of the force adds to
zero, the y component
adds to zero,
the torque adds to zero.
If you've got three equations,
you can plug the numbers into
any of them in any order you
like.
In the end, you will all get
the same answer.
But the way,
to get the answer most
effectively is to take the
torque equation,
because the beauty of the
torque equation is that neither
the vertical part nor the
horizontal part have anything to
do with the pivot enters that.
So, bear that in mind.
Now, you can embellish the
problem.
I don't want to do that.
You can hang a weight here.
I don't think it should cause a
new problem.
Suppose there's an extra with,
a little m,
on top of the mass of the rod.
I am actually hanging a weight
here.
Well, all you have to do when
you go to the torque equation,
is to remember that this weight
going this way will provide an
extra torque.
That will be little m
times g times the whole
length of the rod,
because I'm taking the torque
around that point.
You put that in and you solve
for the tension T;
then go back and,
again, do the force part.
Any questions about this so far?
Because I'm going to do now the
last of these equilibrium
problems before I do something
else.
The last of the equilibrium
problems is very standard fare
for this course,
which is the problem I
mentioned in the beginning to
motivate all of this.
And that is,
if I have a ladder leaning on a
wall at some angle θ,
you can ask yourself,
"Is there a limit to the
θ?"
Do you think there's going to
be some kind of limit,
and if so, what kind of limit
will it be?
A lower limit or an upper limit?
Would you like to guess?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: A lower limit on
the θ?
By that you mean what,
the θ is less than some
amount?
What'll happen?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: It'll fall.
Very good.
So, for equilibrium,
there'll be a lower limit on
θ.
I think it's clear to all of us
that if you're trying to climb a
building and you put a ladder
like this, you are asking for
trouble.
Right?
Yeah?
Student:
So, there's also an upper limit
of θ[inaudible]
you know,
90 degrees [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Look,
I agree.
You mean 91 degrees,
ladder like this.
Yes.
I agree with you.
I don't recommend that either.
So, between--Are you a
mathematician?
Because they always find out
something wrong in anything I
say.
I say, "Good morning," they
say, "Well, not quite you know,
let's look into this."
Philosophers,
even more difficult,
"What is good?
What is morning?
It's morning here,
it's nighttime in California."
But look, every time I make up
an exam for a question I run it
by a lot of students and a lot
of TAs.
Because when I'm talking to
you, I have a certain notion of
what I'm talking about,
but the same words can mean
something else.
And quite often,
I am tripped up by this,
though this is the first that
this question has come up.
So, I learn something every day.
All right.
Anyway, let's say we're going
to limit ourselves 0 to 90.
And what angle can it take?
What's the minimum angle?
What do you think is going to
control that angle?
Yeah?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: The [inaudible]
between the what?
Student:
The bottom of the ladder and
the [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Right.
Okay.
So, in fact,
it turns out even the
coefficient of the friction with
this wall may help,
but we are going to rely on a
problem where the wall is
frictionless and the floor has
the friction.
And it's got a static friction
μ, which I'm just going
to give to you.
So, here is our challenge now.
We want to see why this rod is
not falling.
So, let's just write down all
the equations.
So, whenever you get any
rotation problem,
rule number one is "don't
panic."
Write down the three great
conditions and it will all
happen.
The first condition is,
well, zero condition is,
draw all the forces on this
guy.
So, what forces do you want to
draw?
I think we have learned over
and over Mg can be
assumed to be acting in the
middle of the rod,
the center of the rod.
The wall is very important.
If it's a frictionless wall,
then the only force it can
exert is perpendicular to
itself.
That's the meaning of
frictionless.
You cannot apply a force along
the length of the rod.
So, let's give that name
W for wall.
I come to the floor now.
The floor is exerting a force
N, standard name for
normal or perpendicular.
Then, it's exerting a
frictional force f,
which will be inward.
Because the ladder is trying to
slide out, you will apply a
static frictional force inward
to keep it from moving.
That's it.
These are the forces,
and subject to these forces we
have to write down all the
conditions.
This angle is θ here.
For the x motion,
the fact that all the -- maybe
I should write it -- sum of all
the x forces is zero,
simply it says W = F.
Sum of all the y forces
equals--tells me N =
Mg.
Right.
All that is left is the torque,
and that's where you have the
choice.
You can take the torque around
any point you like.
You can take that point;
in fact, you can take a point
here.
Okay.
If you want to really punish
yourself, you can take a torque
around some crazy point and then
N and f will all
come into problem and you will
have to work that much harder.
So, the trick again,
take the torque here.
Then N and f are
gone, and what do I have?
I have Mg trying to
rotate it this way;
I have W trying to
rotate it that way.
I'm just going to balance the
magnitudes of the two torques.
So, what equations will I get?
For W,
it is W times L
times sin θ.
Now, here is where you
shouldn't simply write it down.
You've got to make sure that
you would have written this
down.
Going back to the definition of
torque, force times distance
from the pivot point times the
sine of the angle between the
force and the line of
separation.
W is the force,
the distance is L -- the
length of the ladder -- and this
θ and that θ are
equal by some theorem we learned
in high school that if you've
got two parallel lines the angle
is the same.
So, the sin θ you want
to use is that.
That's the torque.
That's the torque due to the
wall.
The torque due to gravity is
MgL/2 cos θ.
Now, why did I write cos
θ?
Am I making a mistake?
Instead of sin θ,
why is it cos θ?
Yes?
Student:
Because that angle it makes
with the ladder is the
complimentary of θ.
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Yeah.
So, let me repeat the answer.
When you write torque as MgL
sin θ, the θ is not
some fixed angle that somebody
drew in the diagram.
It varies from force to force.
It's the angle that force makes
with the line connecting the
point of application with the
force to the point of rotation.
So, Mg is acting here.
You want the angle between the
direction of Mg and the
direction of the line of
separation, which is this angle.
We really want the sine of this
angle, but sine of that angle is
cosine of this angle.
So, you can cancel that.
So, I find W equals Mg/2
cos θ.
Just the torque equation tells
me that's the W I need.
The wall's going to push out
with that W,
and you better be able to fight
that.
To fight that,
that W should be equal
to f, which is what we've
got here.
That's fine too.
But now we have a restriction.
f cannot be arbitrarily
big.
f is less than or equal
to the coefficient of static
friction times the normal force.
Yeah?
Student:
Could you explain why you used
the cos θ?
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Yes.
So, I want to find the torque
due to the force of gravity
acting there with respect to
this point.
By the definition of the
torque, you take the force,
you join the point of
application of the force to the
point around which you are doing
the torque and take the angle
between those two lines.
So, it's really that angle,
which is not the θ
here.
But if I draw the picture here,
you can see this is θ,
this is 90 – θ,
this angle that I want.
But then, sine of 90 -
θ is cos θ.
And that's why you use that.
Sine of 90 - θ is
cos θ because when you
change θ and 90 -
θ,
what's opposite becomes
adjacent and what's adjacent
becomes opposite.
In any right triangle,
if that's your angle,
that's called the adjacent
side.
But if that's your angle,
that's called the adjacent
side.
So, sine and cosine exchange
places when θ goes to 90
- θ.
All right.
So, coming back again,
I did this cancellation.
I got that to be equal to the
force of friction but that's
bounded by this.
But I know N = Mg.
So, bring this equation here,
so that's equal to
μ_S times
Mg.
So, I have the restriction that
Mg/2 cos θ--;So,
let's compare that to that and
we find the restriction that
Mg/2 cos θ less
than or equal to
μ_S times
Mg.
You cancel the Mg,
and you find cos θ has
to be less than or equal to 2
times μ_S.
I like to write it as tan
θ has to be bigger than or
equal to 1 over 2 times
μ_S.
Do you know how we went from
here to here?
If this number is smaller than
this number, the reciprocal of
this number is bigger than the
reciprocal of this number.
Three is smaller than 10;
1/3 is bigger than 1/10.
Same thing.
So, I'm somehow used to tangent
better than the cos,
so I flip this over and I flip
that over and I also changed
less than to bigger than.
This way we can understand
tan θ has to be bigger
than some number.
That means θ has to be
bigger than some number,
because tan θ increases
with θ.
So, you tell me what your
coefficient of friction is.
Maybe it's .5, then this is 1.
Tan θ should be bigger
than 1, θ should be
bigger than 45 degrees.
Okay.
Or π /4.
Maybe I should keep using
radians so you guys get used to
radians as a way to think about
it.
So, what's the famous show on
CNN, Anderson Cooper--what?
Anderson Cooper 2π.
That's what it is for this
class.
Think radians or you're going
to screw up somewhere.
Okay?
Angle is what we use every day,
but radians is what we use
here.
When I write a tan θ
and I don't tell you what it is,
or if I tell you tangential
velocity is ω times
r,
that velocity--angular velocity
ω is radians per second.
A lot of people get tripped
over this.
Okay?
It's a very natural way to
measure angles,
and you guys get used to that.
Okay.
So, this is a collection of
problems all in the xy
plane.
Rigid body dynamics is quite
manageable as long as everything
lies in the xy plane.
If the plane of the blackboard
is the xy plane,
notice that everything is
happening in the xy
plane.
All the mass is concentrated on
the plane, all the forces are in
the plane;
all the vectors separating the
point of the torque to the point
of the force are in the plane.
But now, you have to deal with
the fact that in real life
objects are not just planar.
They are chunks like a top or a
potato.
So, living in three dimensions,
and rigid body dynamics in
three dimensions is one of the
most complicated fields.
So, we're not going to do that.
We're going to take a rather
simpler version of the rigid
body problem,
basically the problem of
torques and forces in 3D,
but apply it in a very limited
context.
The limited context I have set
for myself right now is to just
apply it to single point mass.
What does the analogue of τ
= Iα when the mass is not
moving in the xy plane
but just running around all over
three dimensions.
How do you define torque?
How do you define angular
momentum in 3D?
You will find this a--it's not
a straightforward extension.
You have to think a little
harder.
So, let me motivate the problem
we have.
Suppose I have a body in the
xy plane.
Right?
It's a sheet of metal or
something.
And it is spinning and a torque
is applied here.
This is r,
and a force F is applied
here.
This is the kind of problem
we've been studying.
We know that the torque in this
case is going to rotate in a
counter-clockwise direction.
If the forces are opposite it
will rotate in a clockwise
direction.
So, whenever I did a torque
calculation, the torque was
either plus something or minus
something.
Plus meant counter-clockwise,
minus meant clockwise.
If I got ten different torques,
I just add up all of them with
proper attention to plus and
minus signs.
But now, imagine that this body
is actually--You don't even need
a potato for this.
Just take the same flat sheet,
but it's now not living in the
xy plane but floating
somewhere in space,
and somewhere there on its
surface is a force pulling it
with a separation r.
What does that torque do?
The torque will certainly
provide a counter -- let me see
-- a counter-clockwise rotation,
but around this axis,
piercing the sample.
So, we know it's
counter-clockwise,
but it's not enough to say it's
counter-clockwise because in
this problem it is
counter-clockwise around that
axis.
So, when a body is rotated in
more than two dimensions,
the body will tend to rotate
around an axis either clockwise
or counter-clockwise,
but the axis itself has to be
specified.
As long as your body was stuck
to the xy plane,
it had to rotate around
az axis.
I'm just telling you,
if you liberate the condition
and throw it in free space like
Frisbee--A Frisbee can rotate at
any instant.
Here's a flying Frisbee;
it's rotating around some axis.
So, in order to say that the
torque is producing rotations,
we want to characterize not
only the magnitude of the torque
but also tell you the direction
in which it will produce
rotations.
So, there is a trick we use.
The trick is,
we are going to somehow
indicate that the effect of this
torque is to produce a rotation
around that axis.
So, we are going to introduce a
new vector τ;
τ, which was so far a
scalar is going to be now
promoted to a vector.
And the vector will be denoted
by this symbol,
called a "cross product."
But I will now tell you how to
get τ as a vector.
We know r and we know
F.
But the torque,
we suddenly learn,
is actually a vector.
So, well, if it's a vector it
needs a magnitude and it needs a
direction.
The magnitude of the vector is
the old thing,
Fr sin θ.
I hope you people understand
that in three dimensions,
even in three dimensions,
if r and F are two
vectors, you know,
they can move around like these
two fingers;
they define a plane.
And in that plane,
there is a clear angle between
these two vectors.
That's the angle I mean.
So, here is the vector of
r.
If you want,
extend the vector r like
that, that's the θ that
I'm talking about.
Now, once you have two vectors
defining a plane -- here is one
vector, here is another vector
-- there is a perpendicular to
that plane.
Every plane has a perpendicular.
There's only one ambiguity;
it is that if I give you
something planar like this,
I can draw two perpendiculars,
one going up and one going
down.
Both are perpendicular to the
plane.
So, we have to make a choice on
what direction I want to
associate with this τ.
And that's where you use the
right-hand rule.
The rule says--There are lots
of names for this rule.
Let's first take a simple case.
Here is r;
and let me bring the F
vector and draw it like this.
I want to define the cross
product, r cross
F.
Its magnitude is this,
length of r,
length of F,
sine of the angle.
I'm trying to pick a direction.
Either direction,
in this case,
is going to be out of the
blackboard or into the
blackboard.
And the convention is stated in
many different ways.
One convention is,
you take this r and you
turn a screwdriver from r
to F.
Okay?
You guys imagine in your mind;
take a screwdriver,
turn the screwdriver from
r to F.
Which way will this--That's
right.
You see.
That's what all the rap guys
are doing.
They're trying to use the
right-hand rule,
because the right-hand rule
says that if you have an
r and if you have an
F that's the torque.
I've not followed the lyrics
very closely,
but I believe they're muttering
something about forces and
torques.
Okay.
So, here is the right-hand rule.
If this is r and that is
F, then that's the
torque.
But I find it much easier to do
another right-hand rule,
which is like this.
You can see that in books too.
Curl your fingers.
The rule says,
from r to F,
and whichever way your thumb
points, that's the direction of
r cross F.
I think it's very clear if you
write it that way;
that r cross F is
minus F cross r.
So, you've got to be very
careful when you take this cross
product.
The order in which you multiply
the vectors is very important.
Okay.
So, in this example r
cross F--Are you guys
ready now.
I'm not going to tell you the
answer, but think for a second.
r cross F in this
example, if you turn a
screwdriver or do the right-hand
rule, it's coming out of the
blackboard.
That is the direction of the
torque.
You can imagine these two
vectors, which are in the
xy plane;
lift them upon and turn them
into free space.
It doesn't matter.
They still define a
perpendicular direction
uniquely, by turning the
screwdriver from r to
F or curling your
fingers,
or doing whatever you want;
that's the direction of the
torque.
So, torque is a vector.
By the way, that's an
accidental property of living in
three dimensions.
If you take two vectors
A and B,
we can define a cross product
C equals A cross
B.
The rule for what C is
equal to, is that the length of
C is a length of
A,
the length of B and the
sine of the angle between them.
And the direction of C
is found by taking the plane in
which A and B lie
and drawing a perpendicular to
the plane in the sense that you
rotate a screwdriver from
A to B.
If you're living in four
dimensions, if I give you two
vectors like these two fingers,
well, that's perpendicular to
it, you can see,
but there's one other whole
fourth dimension you don't see.
So, in four dimensions,
there is not one perpendicular
direction to a plane.
There are two perpendicular
directions.
So, you cannot take the cross
product and turn it into a
vector in four dimensions.
It's a beautiful property of
three dimensions that one is
able to take two vectors and
manufacture from them a third
vector.
So, that's an accident of 3D,
but we live in 3D so we exploit
this a lot, and it's a natural
quantity to bring in when you
talk about torques.
Now, the whole cross product is
something one can go on and on.
I don't want to talk for too
long.
Let me just point out a couple
of properties of the cross
product.
One is that A cross
B is equal to minus
B cross A,
because when you turn the
screwdriver from A to
B it advances one way.
If it's B to A,
it goes the other way.
One particular consequence of
this is that A cross
A is zero because
A cross A is minus
A cross A;
that means A cross
A is zero.
It also follows from the fact
that the angle between A
and A is zero degrees,
so the sin θ vanishes.
If you want to get practice,
you can practice some simple
cross products.
Here is a unit vector I,
here is a unit vector J,
here is a unit vector K.
So let's try I cross
J.
I cross J is a
vector perpendicular to I
and J,
namely,
pointing in the Z
direction, whose length is equal
to 1 times 1 times sine of 90,
which is 1.
Therefore, this is none other
than K.
I cross J is
K, but that's equal to
minus of J cross
I.
If you went from J to
I, you turned the
screwdriver from J to
I, the screw will go down
the z axis.
So, I cross J and
J cross I are
opposite of each other,
and I cross I is
zero.
By the way, you will find with
your hands one turn would be
easy.
The other would require all
kinds of contortions.
So, what I suggest you do--do
it for the easier one and then
flip the sign because I saw you
going through some unnecessary
torment in the front row.
I have the same problem.
I've seen people doing-- you
know, at my age I shouldn't even
be doing the cross product
because you can end up in the
hospital.
So, anyway, it's a game for the
young.
You can do the cross product
your way, but one day you will
learn to follow my way,
which is do the easy product,
then turn the sign around.
All right.
So, I don't want to spend too
much time, but let me just
mention one thing because of the
homework problem.
Remember the dot product I said
is A dot B,
is length of A length of
B cosine of the angle
between them.
But I told you another way to
do A dot B,
A_xB
_x +
A_yB
_y.
You get that by writing
A as I times
A_x plus
J times
A_y,
likewise for B and
taking all the different dot
products when you open all the
brackets,
that's where you get
A_xB_x +
A_yB_y.
There, because I dot
I is 1 and J dot
J is 1 and I dot
J vanishes for the dot
product.
Cross product is exactly the
opposite.
If you write I times
A_x + J
times J_y +
K times
A_z,
cross product with similar
things for B.
I times
B_x + J
times B_y,
etc.
K times
B_z.
There are, in principle,
nine terms you can get in the
cross product.
Three of them will vanish,
because when you take I
cross I you will get
zero.
When you take I cross
J, you will get
something.
When you take J cross
I, you will get minus
something.
You put them all together -- I
won't do this now -- it will
look like I times
A_xB
_y -
A_yB
_x [correction:
should have said
A_yB_z -
A_zB_y]
plus J times something
and K times something.
I don't need this,
so I'm not going to dwell on
this.
It's good enough for our
purposes to know the cross
product can be visualized as the
vector perpendicular to the two
vectors forming the product and
of length equal to length of
A length of B sine
of the angle between them.
Okay.
So, why did I introduce a cross
product?
Well, here is the point.
I have introduced torque as
r cross F.
I hope you know what that means.
If a force is acting at the
point with vector r
measured from some origin,
the torque due to that force is
r cross F.
Now, I'm going to introduce,
for a single point mass
somewhere here,
an angular momentum,
which is also going to be a
vector.
Previously, angular momentum
Iω was not a vector.
We just say it's spinning
clockwise or counter-clockwise.
Now, for a single point mass,
moving in some direction,
I'm going to introduce the
angular momentum to be r
cross p.
This is an inspired definition
and you will find that it's a
good definition because things
will work out.
What's the first thing this
definition to satisfy?
Anybody have an idea what we
expect?
What relation do I expect
between torque and L?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Torque should be
the derivative of L.
Right.
So, were you going to say that?
So, I expect if things are
working out τ should be
dL/dt.
So, let's see what dL/dt
is.
The rate of change of angular
momentum is going to be
dr/dt cross p plus
r cross dp/dt.
I just used a rule of calculus.
When you've got a product,
you take the derivative of this
and then the derivative of that.
But dr/dt is the
velocity cross momentum plus
r cross the force,
if the rate of change of
momentum is the force.
Now, this guy we like.
That's the torque.
This guy we don't like.
But that'll be zero.
So, you know why that is zero,
v cross p?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: No.
Yes?
Student:
Because p = mv where
v is the same as
velocity.
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Right.
So, velocity and momentum are
parallel.
They're just connected by a
number m.
But if you take two parallel
vectors, their cross product
will vanish because sin
θ = 0.
So luckily, that drops out and
we do have this very nice result
that if I define angular
momentum this way,
then the rate of change of
angular momentum is the torque
where torque was defined as
r cross F.
So, let me convince you that
these definitions in three
dimensions are fully compatible
with what we have been doing all
this time in two dimensions.
Let me convince you this is not
a brand new definition.
Let's go back to 2D and ask,
"What does all of this look
like when I apply it to 2D?"
So, go to two dimensions now.
Let's put that in the--Let's
take some object.
Take a tiny piece of gum stuck
to some rotating rigid body
first.
What do we say is the angular
momentum according to this
formula?
Angular momentum is r
cross p.
This is r.
Right?
If it's a part of the rigid
body, it can only move that way.
I'm first taking the case where
the mass I'm considering is
embedded on a rigid body.
Then when you rotate it,
it has to go along a circle
with that as the radius.
So, the momentum p will
look like that,
and the r measured from
any point will look like this.
r cross p,
which is what I'm calling
L;
the length of L will be
r cross p,
the lengthy of r cross
p, which will be
r.
For p,
let me write mv.
v is tangential velocity
here.
But we both know that that is
equal to m times
ω times r because
the tangential velocity is
ωr.
That something we did long back.
But then this becomes
mω^(2)r.
I'm sorry--mr^(2)ω.
Good.
And mr^(2) is the moment
of inertia of this point mass,
and ω is the angular
velocity of the point mass.
That's what we've been using
all this time.
So, it's fully compatible with
the definition of angular
momentum we had but it's broader
than this one.
This was applicable only to
bodies which are circling some
point because they're stuck on a
rigid body.
That's why this r never
changed and we just went round.
At any instant there is some
ω, it has some angular
momentum.
But I want you to think about
the following fact.
Whenever you take a rigid body
that's made up of many bodies,
each one of them has angular
momentum Iω.
You added them all up.
But as a vector,
each one has an angular
momentum coming out of the
blackboard or going into the
blackboard.
Because if r and
p lie in the xy
plane, then r cross
p lies along the z
axis, either out or in.
That is why both torque and
angular momentum were treated as
scalars and not as vectors.
Because if a vector is
constrained to lie up or down
the z axis,
we can forget about the fact
it's a vector.
We just say it's plus if it's
up and minus if it's down.
That's why in all the early
calculations I did today with
torques it was treated as a
scalar,
but actually the torque was a
vector coming out of the
blackboard or going into the
blackboard.
Next, I've shown you that the
angular momentum you get by this
definition, when applied to a
rigid body -- to a tiny speck on
a rigid body -- is the same as
the angular momentum we've been
using.
But now, I want you to think
about the following notion.
Here is the xy plane
seen from the top.
There is some body which is
rotating.
That's the speck on the body,
for which the angular momentum
written as r cross
p was Iω.
But the speck now flies off.
It breaks loose and takes off.
Does it still have angular
momentum?
If you're doing rigid body
dynamics, you may not be so sure
whether or not it has angular
momentum.
Because angular momentum we
think of as coming from going
round and round something.
Well, this guy's not going
around anything.
Right?
Because it is liberated,
it's taking off like this.
But if you take my definition
that angular momentum as
r cross p,
you'll find that it has angular
momentum even when it's here or
there or anywhere else.
And in fact,
it has the same angular
momentum.
I want to tell you why.
When you are here--Let's take
it that epsilon before it took
off from this rigid body,
it was still stuck to the rigid
body, and the momentum was in
this direction;
r was in this direction,
and the angular momentum was
r times this momentum
p.
What when it's come here?
When it's come there,
r is this bigger vector
r, p is the same
vector p.
It's going at a constant speed.
There are no forces on it.
Has the angular momentum
changed because the r has
become bigger?
But we don't want just r
times p.
We want r times p
times sin θ.
But r sin θ is in
fact--I'm sorry,
θ is the angle between
p and r.
r sin θ is that
perpendicular distance.
That is not changing.
So, maybe I'll draw a better
figure so you understand what I
mean.
Take a body in the xy
plane.
It is just moving like this,
at constant momentum.
What's its angular momentum,
is what we are asking.
The easiest time to compute
angular momentum is when it's
here.
Then, the angular momentum is
that distance r times the
momentum p times sine of
90, which is 1.
If you are over here,
then what happens is,
p is still the same
vector p,
r looks like a longer
vector, but the θ here,
if you put it in,
r sin θ is still the
perpendicular distance.
In other words,
the angular momentum of a
particle with respect to some
origin is the product of the
momentum times the perpendicular
distance you get by
extrapolating its velocity so
you can drop a perpendicular on
it.
Draw a line through the
momentum and drop a
perpendicular on it from the
origin.
That distance times its
momentum is the angular
momentum.
So, every particle,
unless it's going through the
center for which I'm finding the
angular momentum,
will have an angular momentum.
It doesn't have to rotate,
is the main point.
Even a particle in a straight
line has angular momentum,
but I'm trying to show you the
angular momentum here is not
changing with time.
It's not changing because even
as it moves, this component of
r, the r -per
p, is not changing.
We can see that.
No matter where you are,
this distance is not changing.
That's the key to the angular
momentum being a constant.
All right.
Now, if you've got many many
bodies, you glue them together
or they have inter-atomic forces
and they form a rigid body;
then, you can use τ = r
cross F or
dL_i/dt
--dL_i/dt =
τ_i.
Angular momentum of body
i is changing due to the
torque on body i.
You add everything.
Left-hand side will be the
total rate of change of angular
momentum.
Right-hand side will be the
total torque.
Now, the total torque on that
rigid body made up of many point
particles, even if it's not a
rigid body--Just take a bunch of
bodies moving around and find
the rate of change of total
angular momentum.
That's the sum of the total
torques.
You can divide the torque into
the external torque and the
torque internally due to the
forces of one part of the system
on another part of the system.
I'm going in the same way as I
did with momentum.
The rate of change of total
momentum of a system is the
external force plus the internal
forces.
You remember the internal
forces cancelled in pairs.
And therefore we could drop
that, and therefore rate of
change of total momentum was the
external force.
For torque, you may like to,
again, cancel the internal
forces -- internal torques --
because the forces are opposite.
But it's not so obvious you can
cancel them because even though
the force that I exert on you
and you exert on me are equal
and opposite,
to find the torque,
you multiply the force you
exert on me cross product with
the distance of me from the
origin;
whereas, with you it's the
distance of you from the origin.
So, they don't necessarily
cancel.
And you can show that only if
the force the one body exerted
on the other was in the line
joining them;
then that would cancel and
angular momentum would be
conserved.
So, angular momentum
conservation requires more than
just usual momentum
conservation.
Only for the microscopic level,
forces that bodies exert on
other bodies is in the line
joining them is angular momentum
conserved.
Fortunately,
that turns out to be true for
every force we know --
gravitation, Coulomb's Law,
electro-static forces.
All of them have the property
that A exerts a force on
B in the line joining
them.
So, let's take that for granted
and then do the last problem I
want to do for you guys,
which is the gyroscope.
So, here is the gyro.
Now, again, I have to draw this
gyro.
It's another humiliating
experience.
I'm going to try.
So, here is a little tower on
which the gyro is supported.
Now, maybe we can draw it like
this.
It's a disk in this case,
which is spinning like that.
Everybody with me now?
There is a little tower and on
the apex of that you take a
massless rod,
if you like,
put a gyro here.
And first of all suppose it's
not spinning.
I am going to--I'm holding it
here and I'm going to let it go.
What's going to happen to the
gyro is what we're asking.
The gyro is not spinning.
Everybody should know.
You don't need physics 200 or
100 or anything to know what's
going to happen.
If you let it go it's going to
fall.
You want to make sure that
agrees with the equation that we
have, τ = Iα.
Well, the torque on this gyro
is because the mass of the --
the rod has no mass -- the disk
which is sitting there has a
mass mg.
So, torque is equal to
mg times L where
L is the length of this
rod.
That will produce an Iα.
But let's do the torque as a
vector.
What is the vector torque?
I want you guys to think about
that.
Here is r.
The vector r looks like
this.
Right?
Horizontal.
The vector mg looks like
this, treated as a vector.
So, r cross F,
which is really not mgL,
but r cross F is
a general formula which reduces
to mgL.
Now, do the screwdriver rule.
From r to mg,
it goes into the board.
So, we say the angular momentum
of this rod gets an increment
pointing into the board.
We should be very,
very clear that when angular
momentum points into the board
doesn't mean the gyro goes into
the board.
It just means the axis around
which the gyro rotates is
pointing into the board.
It's another way of saying it
rotates like that.
So, the gyro will pick up an
α, which we also assign
as going into the board,
it will just fall down.
So, if you take a gyro and it
doesn't occur to you to spin the
gyro, you might as well get a
piece of stick with an orange at
the end.
What makes a gyro interesting
is the following fact.
You can spin the gyro now.
Now it's a different ballgame.
Suppose the gyro now has an
initial angular momentum.
Which way is it pointing?
That's the first thing you've
got to understand.
This is a spinning disk.
Every part of it is spinning,
and the angular momentum of
every part -- if you do r
cross P -- will all point
outside.
So, one way to find the angular
momentum of the spinning disk is
to have your fingers curl along
the direction of rotation and
the thumb points in the
direction of angular momentum.
So, the gyro has an angular
momentum L pointing that
way.
Let me look at the top view of
this gyro.
The top view of the gyro is
like this.
This is the top of the tower.
Here is my gyro.
It is spinning,
as seen from the top,
like this.
And it's got an angular
momentum L in this
direction.
Okay, this is a pretty dicey
thing.
So, you may have to go home and
read it again.
I don't know how much I can do
right now.
But now let us look at the
impact of the gravitational
torque.
The angular momentum change
ΔL is equal to τ
times the time Δt we
agreed was going into the
blackboard.
That means this L is
getting a little contribution
ΔL in that direction and
that just means the gyro is
going to come to that location.
So, what happens is,
if you have an L to
begin with, you act with the
ΔL like this,
you get the new L +
ΔL, which is just a
rotated L.
That's why the gyro doesn't
fall.
See, for a static rod,
got an angular momentum going
into the board,
it really means it's falling
down like this.
But if a rotating gyro got an
angular momentum on top of an
existing angular momentum,
then the new angular momentum
is now just a rotated angular
momentum.
So, when seen from the top,
the gyro will be doing what's
called a "precession."
If you support it,
it will just slowly go round
and round with this tip here.
Now, does this remind you of
anything you have seen before?
Yeah?
Student:
The Earth rotating around the
Sun.
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Right.
When we did the Earth rotating
around the Sun or any satellite
going around,
it was the same thing.
Here is an apple.
If it's not moving,
the force of gravity acts on
it, causes an acceleration
toward the center.
That means what you and I think
it means, falling toward the
center.
But if you take an apple with a
huge velocity to begin with,
add to it an acceleration
toward the center or a tiny
increment of velocity in this
direction -- we will just give
it that velocity -- and that's
the velocity it has when it has
come here.
Same thing with the gyro.
The gyro does get the same
angular momentum ΔL that
it would whether or not it was
rotating.
But in one case,
you add it to zero and conclude
it's going to fall down;
in the other case,
you add it to L and
conclude that it will rotate.
So, the gyro is constantly
trying to fall down but it's
chasing itself.
Just like this is constantly
trying to fall down and chasing
itself.
So, the last thing I wanted to
calculate is the rate at which
it goes round and round.
That's a pretty easy
calculation.
I will do that and I will let
you go.
So, let's ask the following
question.
Here is the gyro whose angular
momentum was L.
A little later L + ΔL
looks like that.
This is ΔL.
And it rotates in angle
Δθ in some time
Δt.
Then, just from the radians
business you have learned,
I think you guys know that
ΔL is L times
Δθ if θ is in
radians.
That's why I'm cautioning you
to always think in radians.
So, if you rotate the vector by
an angle Δθ,
that segment for small inner
segments is LΔθ.
So, divide both sides by the
time over which it happens.
ΔL/Δt on the left-hand
side is the torque,
and this is L times
what's called the precessional
frequency,
ω_P.
That's what we are trying to
calculate.
So, the precessional frequency
in this problem is equal to the
torque divided by angular
momentum of the gyro.
The torque, and now we can put
the numbers in,
is mg times L.
The angular momentum of the
gyro is some ½ Iω
squared--I'm sorry,
Iω.
Okay, so this
is--Unfortunately,
we don't have the ability to
demonstrate anything in this
room.
But if you looked at the stuff
we have in Sloane [Physics
building], if you take a big
gyro and you spin it,
you suspend one end on the tip
of a tower and it's spinning
like this, you attach some
weight to it,
you will find it starts going
around.
If the gyro is not spinning,
it will just fall down.
If it's spinning,
it's got angular momentum in
that direction to which it gets
an increment in that direction.
So, it goes on rotating.
And if you add more weights to
the gyro, it will rotate faster
because if you add more weights
to the gyro besides its own mass
you will increase this quantity.
All right.
So, we are done with the nasty
part.
So, next week we start
relativity so that you guys can
get something more contemporary.